Just a reminder that
tonight will be at 8:30 in sha Allah.
Starting this evening
will be at 8:30.
[Silence]
We have now completed
two
of the three forms of purification
that we as Muslims perform
in order
to
make our spirits
and make our bodies
pure in a state of purity to be able to
stand in front of Allah
in salah
to be able to make
around the Kaaba
and to be able to handle the words of
Allah
and the Quran.
has mentioned that this
act of
purification
which is known
in the books of as a rough hadath
or
taking a person
out of a state of hadath.
We described and discussed what that
meant before.
He
divides it into two types.
There is purification with water
and there's purification with
the soil, which is tayammum.
And the purification with water is two
types. It's two
types based on a person's
state of being.
And that is that the person
is either in a state of major hadath, in
which he or she must
bathe,
or a person is in a state of minor
hadath, in which the person is to make
wudu.
And we discussed both of those,
alhamdulillah, in great detail.
If we're honest,
if we're honest with ourselves,
unless we
particularly went out of our way
and spent months, maybe even more,
in study,
we are essentially, many of us,
and many people that you meet,
they are making wudu, making salah,
making ghusl,
right? They're doing these things based
on what? Based on whatever they picked
up throughout their lives incidentally.
Incidentally.
I'm speaking from experience.
if we grew up in a Muslim household,
whatever we saw being done, we did.
And throughout our lives, if we saw
something or heard something or picked
something up incidentally along the way,
great.
But that's really the end of it.
What have we done here in this in these
sessions
in the past 6 months or so? I think we
started at the end of Ramadan. So,
that's about 6 months, right?
In the past 6 months, we have now gone
to the actual source.
We actually have relearned these things
from the Quran and from the Sunnah
with evidences.
And we learned
the conclusions drip derived directly
from the narrations and evidences of the
Prophet Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam. This
is a huge achievement.
And let me tell you,
I have met many of men
lying on their deathbeds
frantically scrambling
trying to learn things that they had
their entire life to learn.
To try to get ready
for this most important thing in the
last day or two or week or two of their
lives.
Is that the time to learn?
No.
The time to learn is all the life that
passed. That's when we learn.
A lot of times we don't learn how to
make Salat al-Janazah until someone
dies. That's not the time to learn.
We don't learn to make Hajj or Umrah
until we are forced to go. It's not the
time to learn.
The time to learn is when a person is in
a state of
calm, state of peace. Person may say,
"Well, I'm so busy." You're right.
But this all goes back to the idea
the fantasy
that the companions radiyallahu anhu
were somehow less busy than we are. Let
me tell you,
the companions
lived an infinitely more busy life
to achieve a fraction of what we get
done in an hour in our daily life.
You're right, they weren't day trading
on the stock market, right? They
weren't, you know, making brokering
deals and they weren't,
you know, carrying around cell phones
and yeah, sure.
But a lot of that is busy work. I think,
especially the elders amongst us,
they know that it's busy work.
Imagine if we had to
imagine what the companions had to do
just to make sure there was water to
drink.
Imagine.
You had to get to a well, and the well
was such and such distance. You had to
wait. There's a line at the well. Can't
just jump the line. And people have
herds of cattle and livestock that they
have.
If you want to bathe, you got to make a
fire, and then you got to heat the water
up, and then you got to bathe, and then
you got to
if you want to eat something, you have
to source the food, you have to cook the
food,
right?
Things that we get done
in a fraction of an hour.
We get up in the morning, we take a
shower, we brush our teeth, we, you
know, do all these things, etc., wash
our clothes, press our clothes, do all
these things, and a half an hour these
things are done, eat breakfast, and
we're out the door,
and it used to take them half a day to
get these things done.
But then they had, on top of that, all
of the things we have to do to survive.
They had jobs, they had work, they had
So,
there's no difference between us in the
sense of they had time, we didn't have
time. A lot of times when we think about
the companions, we think about simpler
times.
We imagine that they were just, you
know, just sitting under the tree with
the with the pieces with the straw in
the mouth, you know,
drowsy afternoon, just watching the
goats, you know, come go to and fro and
just sitting around, you know,
playing playing marbles and tossing
rocks. Absolutely not.
They were
rather, you know, exponentially more
busy than we are. But how did they
learn? They made time. They made
sacrifices. That's what's demanded of
you.
So now, we are going to get into
the second half of purification,
which is purification
with
by way of tayammum.
And this, honestly, is one of the most
mysterious things to a lot of people,
but it's one of the easiest things
that a person can learn.
Yes, there's a lot of
rulings and there's a lot of
discussion amongst the scholars of Islam
with respect to the intricacies of
tayammum,
but in practice, tayammum is what?
It's rather simple. And one more thing I
wanted to mention,
looking back at our achievement here in
the past 6 months, not only did we learn
from the Prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam directly, and now we know
for certain a lot of things that we
maybe
knew only by way of rumor or suspected
before, but on top of that, now your
children, those around you, family, they
are learning
from you the cycle of rumors has been
broken.
Because if a person doesn't return to
the source, it's playing a game of
telephone. You remember telephone when
you were kids?
If we have if we got up in into a
if we all lined up
and you whisper something a statement
into one person's ear and then they
whisper it and by the time it reaches
the end it's usually a completely
different thing than the what the first
person said.
Right? And that happens with
the religion and its practices. That
does happen. And that's why even amongst
scholars
the prophet
Alayhi Wasallam tells us that at the
at every 100 years Allah sends a scholar
as a revivalist of the sciences of
Islam.
This is what the prophet
Alayhi Wasallam tells us.
That at every 100 years Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala brings up the scholar of scholars
that acts as a revivalist of his
generation and the generations to come
for the next 100 years. Why?
Because again, this is what happens when
people are not precise, they do things,
they say things and it dulls as it goes
down the row and it has to be revived.
Even the sciences of Islam. You see, if
you are to look in
certain
in the sciences of Islam you can find
places where a major scholar
,
in a land
and then for the next 50, 60, 100 years,
all the other scholars are basically
just disseminating his breakthroughs and
his work.
Right? But then they start to take that
for granted, and even with scholarship,
because knowledge is knowledge is huge.
It's it's a it's an ocean that has no
shore.
Right? And so if if you live 10
lifetimes, you wouldn't be able to
accumulate
,
you know,
the sciences and the knowledge in the
Islamic library. It's just not possible.
So scholars have to rely on other
scholars, especially in fields that is
not their own.
However, even that starts to dull over
time, and it has to be revived. And so
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala sends every 100
years,
he brings up a scholar as a revivalist,
a revivalist of his era. And the
scholars did, you know, they debate
which
scholars in which eras are this one
person, right? And so,
, for instance, in the time of the
Tabi'in, it is most usually cited as,
,
Sa'id ibn al-Musayyib, radiyallahu
rahmatullahi ta'ala. And in the second
century, in the first century,
,
you know, in that second 100 years is
ash-Shafi'i, and in the third 100 years
is at-Tabari, and in the fourth 100
years is
And each scholar has different, ,
different, ,
different educated guesses as to who
this person is, right? We can't say
definitively, but we do know that every
100 years, there's a revivalist.
And this is a huge mercy from Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. If you notice our
religion, especially in the current
time,
we don't have any central caliphate.
We don't have any central
religious figure.
for instance, we don't have a
pope, right? Even Even in Hinduism, they
have certain people that are supposed to
be the incarnation of whatever god or
saint
in order to what? In order to keep
people together. Otherwise, people
splinter because religion is innately
divisive.
However, in our religion, in spite of
not having these things,
the Muslimin are still what? In
agreeance over 90% of all of their
religion. 90%.
And that's why And you want the best
evidence of that? Watch a salah
during Hajj season at the Haram.
Subhanallah, not one person from all
walks of life
comes assuming that Zuhr is five
rak'ahs. Not one.
Not one of them comes assuming that
there is two ruku' and one sujud.
Not one of them
differs on the wording of the Quran.
How is this? This is a miracle from
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. Other
religions, they never had this.
And that's why they had to have prophets
sent.
But, in this
ummah, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has
trusted this ummah so much
that he has left what was for the
prophets in previous nations for the
scholars. And now we all have taken
directly from the scholars of Islam,
directly from the prophet sallallahu
alayhi wa sallam, and we've restarted
the cycle. So, now when we teach our
children, teach them with authority.
When we teach our brothers, we teach
them with authority.
So,
we've taken ghusl and wudu,
and now, inshallah, starting tomorrow,
we'll begin with the rulings of
at-tayammum.
It's not difficult. It's not
complicated. We'll discuss it, and we'll
go through it bit by bit, inshallah
ta'ala.
And then we will move on into the book
of salah, and we will discuss, bi
idhnillah, the rulings of salah,
followed by az-zakah, followed by
fasting, and then after about 50 years,
we'll get to hajj and umrah, inshallah.
And inshallah, by three generations from
now, we'll have finished the book
entirely.